bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau c'est 8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité
la première épreuve du bac arrive à
grands pas pour les lycéens le temps est
aux révisions fiches de lecture ou
encore pour particuliers tous les moyens
sont bons pour être prêt le jour j nous
avons subi une lycéenne qui s'apprête à
passer son bac pro esthétique la
campagne des législatives bat son plein
le ministre de l'écologie nicolas hulot
était dans les yvelines pour soutenir
aurore bergé candidate la république en
marche dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
et puis la finale départementale de
robotique approche à grands pas des dix
établissements seleccion actuellement
les équipes qui porteront leurs couleurs
le collège romain rolland de
sartrouville effectué des compétitions
pour choisir son champion
j - 8 avant la première épreuve du bac
fiche cours particuliers ou encore
mémorisation des leçons tous les moyens
sont bons pour être prêt le jour j
nous avons suivi perrine allouche la
jeune femme de 18 ans au lycée
professionnel florian de sault préparent
le bac pro esthétique histoire français
ou management cinq épreuves attendent
perrine plus qu'une semaine pour réviser
avant de passer son bac pro esthétique
et même si cela ne fait que quelques
jours qu'elle a commencé le planning est
déjà chargé je vais réviser un petit peu
le matin forcément une matière une
première matière une matière dont j'ai
pas moins besoin de réviser comme
l'histoire géo je suis plus tôt à l'aise
donc ça va et après l'après midi je vais
surtout bossé les
grosse épreuve celle de par exemple
d'esthétique et celle de vente où je
sais un peu plus difficile du coup j'ai
plus beau c'est celle ci l'après-midi le
stress commence à monter j'avoue mais ça
va d'après je sais que j'ai réalisé tout
au long de l'année mais cours donc je me
dis que ça va voir et elle est très très
stressé alors là ça va mais on je pense
que cinq jours avant ça va monter petit
à petit ça va monter petit à petit est
en fait la veille faudra pas lui
adresser la parole
un stress que perrine arrive quand même
à maîtriser sa méthode accompagner ces
révisions de musique ou d'une série pour
bien m'occuper en même temps enfin je
préfère faire plusieurs choses en même
temps parce que sinon je suis pas motivé
pour faire mais si sur pet
voilà ça me permet de me motiver mais de
la musique ce fait des fiches tout
simplement
après moi je sais que je relis aussi
beaucoup mes cours les définitions
surtout les mots importants
après si une phrase qui me paraît très
importante je vais l'a marqué mais après
c'est pour l'assistance des abréviations
voilà c'est les choses les plus
importantes soit c'est l'un d'eux
exactement faire en cours parce que
chien ça c'est rien de le recopier comme
près de 700 mille candidats en france
perrine est attendu jeudi 15 juin pour
la première épreuve
c'est la première fois qu'elle passe cet
examen et elle espère bien la dernière
vous l'avez peut-être aperçu si vous
êtes passés devant l'école élémentaire
marcel pagnol de coignières des élèves
en cm1 ont mis en place une exposition
dans le cadre des itinéraires politique
de saint quentin en yvelines
objectif de ce projet crée un lien entre
la photographie la poésie écoutez gilles
cheval
il a participé à l'initiative
l'idée d itinéraire poétique à la fin du
projet c'est toujours de faire un objet
donc un livre ou dans le cas présent qui
permet aux enfants de repartir avec un
souvenir et puis surtout ça permet de
finaliser vraiment le projet les enfants
généralement sont sensibles aux livres
même si les écrans prennent de la place
de plus en plus le livre est toujours
une place très privilégié pour les
enfants
un livre c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment magique
on passe à la politique et la course aux
législatives continue à quelques jours
du premier tour tous les moyens sont mis
en oeuvre pour gagner des voix et la
république en marche la bien compris le
ministre de l'écologie nicolas hulot est
venu dans les yvelines soutenir aurore
bergé candidate dans la 10e
circonscription
regardez un soutien de poids pour aurore
bergé dans la course à la députation la
candidate de la république en marche la
10e circonscription rencontrer ce
mercredi nicolas hulot l'actuel ministre
d'état de la transition écologique a
visité avec la femme politique les
étangs de hollande construit sous louis
xiv on est au coeur d'une
circonscription rurale encore d'une
circonscription où la biodiversité la
protection de l'environnement la
protection de la nature doivent être au
coeur de nos priorités des étangs que
l'ancien présentateur de télévision et
ambassadeurs de l'environnement connais
bien le ministre a vécu à saint léger en
yvelines pendant une dizaine d'années il
ya derrière ça aussi un message c'est
qu'il ya l'aspect récréatif régénérant
des forêts mais notre sort est lié à la
protection et la réhabilitation des
écosystèmes donc à mes futurs aux futurs
députés j'espère pouvoir faire ce
plaidoyer en direct comme je vais le
faire dans le gouvernement lance
aujourd'hui dans le gouvernement de la
république en marche nicolas hulot n'a
pas apporté son soutien au candidat
écologiste sur la circonscription david
jutier un choix qu'il assume les
paradoxes sont nombreux mais ce qu'on
voit bien avancé qu'il ya un rabattage
l'écart alors ça vous en france dans le
monde voyez bien quand même que tout et
où toutes les alliances habituel encore
une fois moi je suis pas là pour faire
une campagne contre les uns et les
autres après avoir vraiment besoin de
tout le monde
pressez des électeurs de choisir le
week-end prochain en fonction de leur
sensibilité dans la 10e circonscription
des yvelines aurore bergé sera l'une des
favorites pour le poste de député la
candidate de 30 ans devra notamment
batailler face au député sortant
jean-frédéric poisson du parti chrétien
démocrate en politique toujours le npa
ne présente qu'un seul candidat dans les
îles
line et c'est vincent fournier dans la
11e circonscription un postier de 33 ans
qui espère surfer sur la médiatisation
de philippe poutou lors de la
présidentielle
un reportage de nicolas quere levitt un
tract du npa philippe poutou le camp des
travailleurs la lutte contre la réforme
du code du travail
le message est rodé pour le seul
représentant du npa dans les yvelines
vincent fournier facteur depuis une
dizaine d'années et candidat dans la 11e
circonscription
la tâche est forcément compliqué même
sur un territoire ancré à gauche porter
les idées de philippe poutou le candidat
du parti à la présidentielle
le programme de la campagne en fait
c'est essentiellement un programme
d'urgence
l'interdiction des licenciements
l'augmentation des salaires de 300 euros
net et dans la répartition du travail
entre tous avec en allant vers les 32
heures tout de suite candidats déjà en
2012 sur la troisième circonscription
des yvelines vincent fournier avait
recueilli à l'époque 0,22 % des
suffrages exprimés
il espère dépasser cette fois ci la
barre des 1% avec des moyens logiquement
réduit
on a l'habitude toutes façons distribué
des tracts c'est l'essentiel de la
campagne toute façon et coller les
affiches sur les panneaux donc c'est
nous on a l'habitude de tous ordres pour
cette élection le candidat du npa mène
campagne avec claude normand une
retraitée du secteur privé le binôme
souhaite surtout mobiliser les électeurs
pour l'avenir notre objectif c'est de
construire de construire une capacité de
lutte un parti des rassemblements
des personnes capables de descendre dans
la rue quand ce sera nécessaire pour
défendre les intérêts des travailleurs
donc notre objectif il n'est pas
purement campagne électorale il est
vraiment un travail en profondeur dans
la durée au total treize candidats sont
présents sur la 11e circonscription des
yvelines parmi eux le député sortant et
candidat à la présidentielle benoît
hamon nadia est candidate de la
république en marche ou encore le maire
d'elancourt et ancien député jean michel
fourgous direction la 10e
circonscription des yvelines philippe
chevrier ex front national est le
candidat du front libéré il souhaite
prendre la place du député sortant
jean-frédéric poisson ses axes de
campagne
la limitation de l'immigration et la
réduction des dépenses publiques la
priorité c'est de sortir de l'euro c'est
évident parce que
mais c'est une chose que de redresser
les comptes publics
c'en est une autre de résoudre le
chômage
alors mettons que ça nous coûte ici en
france de sampo pâte pour fabriquer un
produit 15 points de productivité de
moins ça veut dire que en allemagne on
peut le faire pour 85 bon pour les
français des centres de 100 à 85 étant
donné qu'à masse salariale c'est à peu
près 30% des coûts eh bien il faut
baisser la masse salariale de 30 à 40%
d'autres candidats briguent aussi le
poste de jean frédéric poisson c'est le
cas de laurent burson candidat du parti
libéral-démocrate ils souhaitent faire
entendre ses idées et invite les
libéraux de conviction à le soutenir
dans sa campagne le revenu universel que
l'on prône va'a est en remplacement de
d'autres d'autres aides et en complément
pour certaines mais n'est pas une aide
sociale supplémentaire
j ai donné
aux français il ya forcément et cette
17è de ce revenu universel va est en
lien avec
la mise en place d'un regard d'un impôt
prélevé à la source
identique pour tous dire avec le même
pourcentage pour tous voilà ccc en fait
c'est un projet global de réunions
publiques
à noter la première françois-xavier
benami candidats aient l'air dans la
première circonscription organise une
réunion publique aujourd'hui à 20h30 au
cinéma le cyrano à versailles dans la
deuxième réunion publique organisée par
jean-guy ça use candidat dvd dans la 2e
circonscription se déroule aussi ce soir
à 20h30 à la salle municipale et ingrid
bergman à choisel quatre collèges un
vainqueur le 9 juin c'est le 18ème sic
mythe le championnat intercollèges de
match d'improvisation théâtrale sur
scène s'affronteront plusieurs
établissements saint quentinois dont le
collège albert einstein de magny les
hameaux que nous avons suivi durant
l'une de leurs répétitions
regardez il s'agit du collège albert une
fille de ma vie vainqueur
du trophée 2016
il est vrai que le trophée de match
d'improvisation intercollèges restent
chez eux les mails une quoi du collège
albert einstein revoient leurs gammes
l'idée aujourd'hui et sur le court
prochain c'est tenter des choses
d'accord tenter des mises en scène
prenez des risques amusez vous ok
on se précisent sur certains certains
sujets comme la on a vu les balances
donc c'est le fait que yanakis tête on
en a d'autres qui sont qui sont par
terre et inversement
en fait on revoit un peu tout ce qu'on a
travaillé pendant l'année mais en ayant
plus de liberté deux minutes c'est parti
je pense que c'est la diversité des jeux
parce qu'on a joué assez différent fait
enfin des actes des comédiens des petits
commerces à 16 10 mai des élèves de
l'équipe donc je pense que c'est ça qui
fait la force
ils ont entre 11 et 14 ans ils partent
comme favoris à quelques jours du
concours ces collégiens et sont d'une
certaine pression
leur coach en toile donne ses derniers
conseils il faut une histoire plus
construite que sa plus importante que ça
des gens on essaie de les détendre parce
que malgré tout c'est des événements qui
sont hyper impressionnant pour eux ils
sont dans des grandes salles ya tous
leurs copains qui viennent les voir
donc on essaye de les rassurer en
en les enrichissant
mais c'est en blindant on essaye l'inde
est ce qu'ils savent déjà faire plus que
deux marches à gravir pour inscrire à
nouveau leur nom sur le trophée
ils n'ont qu'une idée en tête et on leur
souhaite bonne chance
la finale départementale de robotique
c'est bientôt les 10 établissements
sélectionnés choisissent actuellement
les équipes qui porteront leurs couleurs
direction le collège romain rolland de
sartrouville
il effectue une compétition pour choisir
son champion quel robot représentera le
collège romain rolland de sartrouville à
la grande finale du concours robotique
initiée par le conseil départemental
c'est ce que doit définir aujourd'hui ce
jury déjà impressionné par le circuit
reflet de l'implication des élèves comme
l'expliquent mathieu lemaitre étudiants
alice ti qui les a épaulé tout au long
du projet ils ont vraiment su développer
quelque chose autour de la ville du
futur qui était le sujet principal
on sent qu'ils y ont mis leur coeur leur
motivation et leur vêtus de tous les
jours pour en arriver là les élèves ont
même travaillé en dehors du temps
scolaire
une fierté pour le proviseur c'était pas
un projet qui était facile au départ
c'est des élèves qui sont très impulsifs
mais qui ont démontré leur capacité de
travail en équipe de faire des
concessions de faire des choix et les
assumer jusqu'au bout
savoir assumer une valeur importante
souligné à plusieurs reprises par le
jury notamment lors du passage de cette
équipe venue sans robot on n'a pas eu de
repos à cause d'un élève qui a voulu
changer les
et capteurs mais il n'a pas eu le temps
de les replacer pendant plus d'une heure
chacune des quatre équipes tentent de
convaincre le jury sont évidemment
évaluer les performances du robot mais
également la présentation orale ça s'est
assez bien passé
on essaie de faire comme on pouvait
malgré les 20 être un petit peu de
stress
c'était bien mais lorsque le robot n'a
pas pu compléter leur gamme et que la
programmation soit parfaite pour la
présenter devant le proviseur le verdict
tombe c'est l'équipe futur x qui
représentera l'établissement ça s'est
bien passé on avait un bon il ya une
très bonne équipe on sait tous répartis
les tâches y avait une bonne entente
dans la salle désormais soutenu par les
autres équipes futur x doit peaufiner
son robot pour affronter ceux des neuf
autres collèges qui participeront à la
grande finale le 12 juin
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]